if we want to know who leaked the
special counsels long list of questions
for the president we need to ask who
stands to the most to gain well the
former assistant to Bob Muller blamed
President Trump for the leak but Trump
blasted the leak himself in a tweet
earlier today a report in The Washington
Post tonight though suggests that the
leaked list may be a series of questions
come by outlet by Trump attorney Jay
Sekulow it may have actually been a list
of questions that the president's legal
team believed Trump would be asked kind
of a moot court situation let's ask to
top legal minds why they think the list
was leaked former US Attorney for the
District of Columbia Joe digenova and
former whitewater deputy independent
counsel saw Weisenberger Joe let's start
with you I mean the intrigue about who
leaked what and who has motive I mean
it's like Columbo here Joe but I
actually I actually don't care who
leaked it now I think what's important
is is that these are clearly the types
of questions that have been discussed
between the president's team and mr.
Muller and the question is what do these
questions say they say that the
investigation is now lurching into
territory protected by the
constitutional privileges of the
President of the United States and that
if Muller let's assume these questions
are accurate that this is what Muller
wants to ask if they are and if he
insists on answers and will not accept a
written answers and demands an interview
which the president rejects and then
Muller insists on a subpoena we are
headed to a constitutional crisis
because the president's not going to
answer these questions under any set of
circumstances all when I saw tonight
this report in The Washington Post about
the presidential subpoena you know the
tick's takes kind of a lot to shock me
these days in Washington but I took a
couple of extra breaths there your
reaction I'm not sure I saw the post
thing is there a presidential this is a
subpoena already issued to the president
no it's just it's just apparently Muller
raised the possibility with the Trump
legal team reported
well I think Joe is absolutely right
if if President Trump decides not to ant
not to sit in for an interview and
answer these questions and these are
very broad questions that definitely
raise issues of both executive privilege
and separation of powers if he declines
to answer and and Muller issues a
subpoena you know it's not just a
question of this Trump invoked the Fifth
Amendment or go to the grand jury he's
going to go and litigate this issue and
here's something that is very
interesting that I don't believe anybody
has talked about remember in the
Watergate years you had US versus Nixon
where the Supreme Court rejected
President Nixon's blanket claims of
executive privilege but in that decision
they pointed out that Leon Jaworski the
Special Counsel have been explicitly
granted the power to contest executive
privilege I'm not sure Bob Muller has
the power under his appointment from Rod
Rosenstein or under the regulation to go
in and even challenge the executive
privilege so there's a possible third
way for the president to bottle this up
in court
very executive privilege I love that Joe
that's fascinating any particular
questions in this lengthy list yes
jumped out at you and why yes the
questions the putative Li posed by
Muller about what were you thinking when
you fired Comey what were you thinking
when you fired Flynn the notion that a
Special Counsel
can intrude on the thinking process of a
sitting president while he was admiring
a person that you have ultimate
authority unfettered unreviewable
authority to fire under the Constitution
tells me one thing about Muller
he has gone goofy the the question
should not be answered under any set of
circumstances and I tell you something I
would litigate this to a fare-thee-well
these questions are sophomoric
Sall any particular questions that you
have in mind
that would be especially problematic for
this president to ant
I mean I wouldn't as a lawyer I would
not recommend that he do this interview
under any circumstances I didn't think
so before and I certainly don't think so
now maybe some written answers like you
know maybe maybe a poetry or a haiku I'd
send back to Muller but at this point I
wouldn't be I wouldn't be engaging with
that group - I agree with you I didn't
think he should go in before - that I
mean you could pick any number of them
that - - that struck me as particularly
outrageous are almost humorous one why
do you continue to criticize Jim Comey
and Andrew McCabe I mean give me a break
you need to be you need to ask that
that's rather obvious and one other one
was why did you hold you know Jeff
Sessions attorney General Sessions
resignated resignation in abeyance I
think until May 31st and who did you
discuss it with again as Joe points out
this goes into the heart of executive
decision making and but it also shows
something else these questions show a
couple of things
the Muller people are outraged and livid
at the president's criticisms of them
and they have a very dangerously broad
view of obstruction of justice Joe and
Saul I want to play for you now a
soundbite from rod Rosenstein today he
was at an event and he was reacting to
what he had heard and been reported
about the freedom caucus potentially
drawing up articles of impeachment
against Rosenstein this is what he said
they can't even resist leaking their own
drafts I just don't have anything to say
about documents like that that nobody
has the courage to put their name on and
that they leaked in that way but I can
tell you there were people who have been
making threats privately and publicly
against me for quite some time and I
think they should understand by now the
Department of Justice is not going to be
extorted Joe well I think mr. Rosenstein
has just shown his ignorance of the
Constitution Congress has demanded
access to documents that it's entitled
to under the Constitution pursuant to
its oversight function his refusal and
obstructionism to turn over those
documents has led to the confrontation
which is why they are considering his
impeachment if he thinks that's
extortion
I suggest that he resigned from office
because he's clearly a legal incompetent
yeah Meadows are suggesting that
basically today saw that I mean this all
exertion Dacula this extortion line I
mean it's as as the Deputy Attorney
General to throw around the word
extortion when you're already sorry
under a cloud of concern at the very
least because of some of the makeup of
the of the prosecutors what's happened
with the text messages the failure
prosecutors widen pick the prosecutor I
mean rod Rose I'm talking about over the
investigation and for in a prickly it
was like a Comey asked priggish prickly
manner to go well I can't believe it I
just thought it just looked under
finding the fight you see is a man don't
please don't please don't please don't
defame rod by comparing him to Comey
I've had these you've you've had these
these fights but what is it you think
it's okay for Trump to claim executive
privilege visa V Muller but it's not
okay for roses Stein to talk to resist
Congress that's been going on since
Hector was a pup and you know it it's a
bad I don't have any problem he can
resist Congress but he cannot refuse to
turn over documents that Congress has a
right to see but but here's the point
that use of the word extortion today was
an absolute outrage on the part of a
constitutional officer who is the Deputy
Attorney General of the United States
that is unbecoming and it's a fireable
offense he's not going to be fired
everything's an outrage everything
outraged actually actually that's not
true saw and and in fact when the Deputy
Attorney General of the United States
uses the word extortion for Congress
seeking documents it's entitled to an
oversight that is out so all I say is
look the only reason they ever the only
reason they ever turned over the
documents is because they were about to
be slapped with contempt of Congress
that they had to go to that level to get
the documents that they're entitled to
get under their normal constitutional
oversight obligee
it's an obligation Roger you know what
the the president the president actually
is is higher up than rod Rosen Stein
it's amazing thing in our system of
government at any time in the last six
months the president could have picked
up the phone and told Ron yeah we got
instead of China
no no not part him he could have said
rod turn that stuff over and then rod
could have been he's been total kebab
and talked ridiculous has been told he
cannot communicate with we're gonna run
my chair with Don Magan does he's
obviously not how a president guys thank
thank you both but you're right he would
have been creamed politically in PR wise
by the press and so forth and he was
advised not to do that